aujourd'hui on est le jeudi 22 septembre
c'est le début du casu open de france
historique de cet open de france il a
été créé en 1906 est l'un des plus vieux
tournoi continental d'europe il est
depuis 1991 ici au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à part deux
éditions est petite particularité il est
de retour cette année en 2019 ils
avaient eu lieu c'était la dernière fois
avec la victoire de nicolas colsaerts le
belge et il est de retour et forcément
le public est venu nombreux ici autour
des greens écoutez c'est la première
fois que je viens mais je trouve que
c'est intéressant avec des grands
joueurs qui sont là aujourd'hui je
serais sûrement apprendre des choses
c'est très intéressant on n'était pas
venu puis 2019 ça commençait à nous
manquer
nicolas colsaerts qui a gagné en 2019
donc on va venir le voir jouer à nouveau
ma famille et belges alors c'est pour ça
donc on la soutient c'est encore une
belle occasion de
de voir voilà les meilleurs golfeurs
c'est vrai que le premier jour c'est
intéressant parce que
voilà tout démarre il ya déjà des déjà
des scores il ya déjà
des résultats
et cette année sur les greens il y à du
beau monde il y a les français notamment
avec thomas levet qui fait son grand
retour il avait remporté en 2011 cet
open de france ici et il s'était cassé
la jambe juste après avoir remporté le
trophée on s'en souvient tous il y a
également barjon qui est l'une des têtes
d'affiché du sport français actuellement
du golf français et il ya des américains
comme par exemple avec patrick reed qui
étaient présents ici lors de la ryder
cup c'était en 2018 si
le terrain de golf ressemble à 2018 mais
c'est juste un peu plus ferme et plus
rapide que ce que j'ai pu connaître dans
le passé ici sur ce parcours
[Musique]
pas mes côtés le directeur du golf
national de 50 ans les vignes filippi
lato ans directeur heureux aujourd'hui
pour cet open de france se son quatrième
open de france
très heureux déjà de retrouver de
retrouver l'événement après deux années
deux années sans son tournoi remet très
heureux de revoir un petit peu et de
ressentir le stade mosphere de deux
tournois professionnels ou à rome du
public parce que je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui très honnêtement il y
avait qu'un pas mal de public autour de
autour d'eux des différentes parties
qu'on est donc super score super météo
ont l'impression que c'est un peu une
habitude ici au golf national de saint
quentin en libye à la ryder cup il
faisait exceptionnellement beau là
encore il fait beau ouais c'est vrai
qu'on a de la chance avec la météo est
plutôt bonne la météo est bonne jusqu'à
dimanche il me semble donc effectivement
on est un petit peu chanceux donc ça
nous coûte cher ça nous coûte cher en
galerie mais effectivement ça marche
mieux on recommencera peut-être
certainement les prochaines alors du
soleil et également de très bons joueurs
ici sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines peut-être l'un des
plus beaux plateaux depuis 2017 ouais
c'est vrai qu'on a un plateau qui est
incroyable c'est vrai qu'on a on a la
chance d'avoir patrick reed qui joue le
tournoi la chance d'avoir mcintyre qui a
gagné la semaine dernière en italie donc
des joueurs qui sont entrés très en
forme et après derrière ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a aussi un
volume de 29 joueurs français qui sont
présents ce qu'ont joué les championnats
du monde amateurs donc ça c'est génial
et puis après des joueurs des locaux
avec antoine ros mère qui est là victor
perez qui est qui est vraiment très en
forme qui a fini troisième la semaine
dernière en italie donc on a un plateau
vraiment qui est incroyable il te fait
cette année du spectacle forcément sur
les greens de l'albatros ouais ouais les
gars et les gars ils ont fait ce qu'il
fallait préparer le terrain comme il le
fallait le terrain qu'on pouvait le voir
librement incroyablement beau et je
pense qu'il est le parcours est un petit
peu plus ouverts comme on dit dans le
jargon c'est à dire un petit peu plus
jouable dans ce qui veut dire qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup de birdy beaucoup de
spectacles à voir oui tout à fait un
petit mot aussi sur le revenant thomas
levet qui a gagné ici en 2011 qui
s'était fracturé la jambe on s'en
souvient à l'époque qu'est ce que ça
vous fait de voir thomas levet ici jouer
au golf national ben c'est bien c'est
bien de revoir thomas et puis en plus
thomas c'est aussi un enfant du pays un
thomas vient du racing club de france à
côté j'ai toujours en mémoire de thomas
kuhn est souvent s'entraîner ici et de
le retrouver après sa victoire sur le
site avec le sourire et voilà la bonne
humeur qu'on le connaisse et c'est
toujours c'est toujours un vrai plaisir
à la question si vous êtes très fort
dans ce jeu là les pronostics est ce que
vous voyez un français gagner cette
année alors ouais bien sûr alors je ma
sensibilité moi je verrais bien un
antoine ganyé antoine rosemère avec
derrière je pense que mcintyre risque de
pas être très loin et après je pense qu
en troisième place je serais encore ils
tracent chauvin je mettre un victor
perez on regarde la vidéo merci beaucoup
aux philippines à tôt
[Musique]
cette 104ème édition de l'open de france
se terminera ce dimanche 25 septembre
ici au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour l'instant environ trente
mille personnes sur les quatre jours de
compétition
[Musique]